john and kate gosselin divorced more
than a decade ago but it seems that they
really never resolve their issues
especially when it comes to their eight
children
well now their ongoing custody battle
just went from bad to worse
after their 16 year old son colin
accused his dad of physical abuse
yesterday he beat me colin wrote
adding he punched me in the face and
gave me a swollen nose and i started
bleeding
he then continued to kick me in the ribs
colin's post which has since been
deleted was written last week
john told us colin has endured severe
trauma
claiming previously it happened while he
was attending a special needs facility
i have to take like parenting therapy to
understand where he's coming
from the hardest part is when there's an
incident
or something happens and remember
it's not about you or something against
you
it's the trauma and what happened
john flat out denies hurting his son his
rep tells e.t
john has never abused colin no charges
have been filed against him
and there's no ongoing investigation
what's interesting is that colin seemed
upbeat a few days after the alleged
incident
posting this new haircut selfie sunday
and writing that he was quote
doing better than ever we've determined
now that
colin is me and i am him so this has
become a pandemic
revelation in our household so he really
is your kind of mirror
and now you're looking at yourself yeah
complete personality
and for john's birthday in april colin
posted this pic calling john
the coolest most amazing dad the drama
is just the latest he said
she said since john and kate's nasty
split in 2009.
i want my kids off television the kids
obviously are still in his life because
he's their dad and they visit him from
time to time but
otherwise he lives his own life
you have not seen colin two years i used
to go to school and see him and then
he's homeschooled i'm like hey why don't
you come he's like well
you know mommy you know doesn't let me
down and i it felt like she was just
segregating me from him
[Applause]
because they're over 14 in pennsylvania
custody is up to them so like my custody
i have custody of hannah and colin and
she has custody of four and men in care
are adults
my kids and colin that live with me want
to be left alone and they just want to
have a normal teenage life